PRESENTER: Please
welcome Allie Brosh.
[APPLAUSE]
ALLIE BROSH: OK, so
I'm going to read
you the first story in the book.
So if you haven't
read the book yet,
you're getting a head start.
Let me make sure my
clicker's working.
When I was 10 years old, I
wrote a letter to my future self
and buried it in my backyard.
17 years later, I
remembered that I
was supposed to remember to
dig it up two years earlier.
I looked forward to
getting a nostalgic glimpse
into my childhood.
Perhaps I would marvel
at my own innocence,
or see the first glimmer
of my current aspirations.
As it turns out, it just made
me feel real weird about myself.
The letter was scrawled
in green crayon
on the back of the utility bill.
My 10-year-old self
had obviously not
spent much time planning
out the presentation of it.
Most likely, I had simply been
walking through the kitchen,
and suddenly realized
it was entirely
possible to write a
letter to my future self.
The overwhelming excitement
of this realization
probably cause me to
panic and short circuit,
making me unable to locate
proper writing elements.
There was no time for
that kind of thing.
I did, however, manage to
fight through the haze of chaos
and impulse long enough to
find a crayon stub and a paper
surface to match it against.
The letter begins thusly.
"Dear 25-year-old."
Note, not dear 25-year-old
me, or dear 25-year-old self.
Just dear 25-year-old.
Do you still like dogs?
What is your favorite dog?
Do you have a job training dogs?
Is Murphy still alive?
Foreshadowing.
What is your favorite food?
Are mom and dad still alive?
I feel it's important to note
the order of those questions.
Obviously, dog-related
subjects were my chief concern.
Murphy was my family's
dog, followed closely
by the need to know my
future favorite food.
I feel that the
double question marks
speak to how important
that question was.
And you guys can't
see that, but there
were double question
marks in there.
Only then did I pause to
wonder whether my parents had
survived.
[LAUGHTER]
The letter continues with a
section titled, "About Me."
My name is Allie, and
I am 10 years old.
I have blonde hair
and blue eyes.
My favorite dog is
a German Shepherd.
My second favorite
dog is a husky.
My third favorite dog
is a Doberman Pinscher.
This is troubling for a number
of reasons, the first of which
is that I apparently thought
my future self wouldn't
be aware of my
name or eye color.
[LAUGHTER]
The second thing is
the fact that I just
tacked on my favorite
dog breeds at the end
there, like it was every bit
as important to my identity
as the other things, as if
my past self had imagined
my future self standing in the
yard, above the upturned earth,
clutching my letter
and screaming,
but what dogs did I like?
How am I supposed to understand
my identity without knowing
what dogs I liked when I was 10?
I take a break from
writing at that point
to draw several pictures of what
appear to be German shepherds.
Below the German shepherds, I
wrote the three most disturbing
words in the entire letter,
three words that revealed more
about my tenuous
grasp on reality
than anything else I have
uncovered about my childhood.
There at the bottom
of the letter,
I had taken my
crayon stub and used
it to craft the
following sentence.
"Please write back."
[LAUGHTER]
Judging by the thick,
purposeful lines in each letter,
I was applying a truly
impressive amount of pressure
to the crayon.
The sincerity of the
request is unmistakable.
When I asked my future self
what my favorite dog is,
or whether my mom and
dad were still alive,
I actually expected
to get answers.
And apparently, I still
expected to be 10 years old
when I got those answers.
"Please write back."
I imagine myself patiently
standing in the yard,
day after day,
thinking, any time now.
It's going to happen soon.
I just know it.
Time travel is a
complex subject that I
don't expect a 10-year-old
to fully understand.
But this is more than just
a basic misunderstanding
of time travel.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm almost definitely
not a time traveler.
But in case I am, I
decided to write back.
In fact, I decided
to write letters
to several iterations
of my past self,
because I felt there were
important things I could
explain to myself or things
I could warn myself about.
Allow me to begin with a
letter to my two-year-old self.
Dear two-year-old, face
cream is not edible.
No matter how much it
looks like frosting,
no matter how many
times you try,
it's always going to be face
cream and never frosting.
I promise I wouldn't
lie to you about this.
It's honestly never
going to be frosting.
For the love of
fuck, please stop.
I need those organs
you're ruining.
Dear four-year-old.
Allow me preface this
by saying that I don't
know why you started eating
salt in the first place.
But regardless of the
precipitating circumstances,
there you are.
As soon as you became aware
that eating huge amounts of salt
is really, really
uncomfortably salty,
you should have
stopped eating salt.
That's the solution.
The solution is not
to begin eating pepper
to cancel out the salt.
You've found yourself in this
predicament several times now.
And every time, you get trapped
in this totally preventable
cycle.
You've done more than
enough experimenting
to come to the conclusion
that pepper is not
the opposite of salt
all by yourself.
But somehow, you seem to
remain stubbornly unaware
of this fact.
[LAUGHTER]
To reiterate, no matter
how much pepper you eat,
it won't undo the
ludicrous amount of salt
you ate before it.
The only thing you're
accomplishing by eating pepper
is making your mouth taste
like pepper and salt.
Similarly, switching
back to salt
again won't cancel
out the burning
from the pepper you ate to
cancel out the original salt.
How is this so
difficult to understand?
You can stop whenever
you want to do.
As a side note, you
really need to start
learning from your mistakes.
Believe me, I know
what happens when
you discover electric
fences next year.
And you could do without that
seventh jolt of electricity.
Dear five-year-old.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Normal children don't have
dead imaginary friends.
Normal children don't
pick open every single one
of their chicken
pox scabs and then
stand naked and bleeding
in the darkened doorway
to their bedroom until
someone walks past and asks
what they are doing.
Furthermore, normal children
don't respond by saying,
I wanted to know what all
my blood would look like.
Normal children also don't
watch their parents sleep
from the corner of their room.
Mom was really scarred by "The
Exorcist" when she was younger,
and she doesn't know how to
cope with your increasingly
creepy behavior.
Please stop.
Please, please stop.
Dear six-year-old.
You're having an absurdly
difficult time learning
the letter R. You
practice all the time,
and you have mastered every
other letter in the alphabet,
both uppercase and lowercase.
But for reasons beyond
my comprehension,
R just destroys you.
Look at this.
How does that happen?
How do you mess
something up that badly?
The first one is understandable.
But what's going on
with that middle one?
Have did that extra
protrusion get there?
And look at the tiny
one on the right.
That one has four protrusions.
I'm not an expert
on protrusions,
but that's way too many.
I think if you took some
time to relax and really
look at the letter R, you'd
see that it's not nearly as
complicated as you're making it.
Dear seven-year-old.
Look at the other
children around you.
Do you see how they're
wearing clothing?
That's because they're
seven years old,
and they've all
realized that it's
no longer appropriate to take
their clothes off in public.
But you haven't
realized that, have you?
People have tried to
explain it to you.
Your teachers have tried.
Your parents have tried.
Even the other students
have expressed discomfort
with your persistent and
inexplicable nakedness.
But you just don't stop.
Why do you want to
be naked so badly?
Do you even know why?
Are you overtaken by
forces beyond your control
that make you do this?
Regardless, clothing
is a reality
that you need to accept.
There are no loopholes to this.
You can't take your
clothes off and hide
in the corner hoping
no one notices.
You can't trick the
teachers into letting
you be naked by burying
yourself in the sandbox.
Your clothes are in
a pile next to you.
They know.
Dear 10-year-old.
Wow, you really like dogs.
In fact, you like dogs
so much, that I'm not
even sure it's
emotionally healthy.
It might be normal
to love dogs a lot,
or to be really
interested in dogs.
But you go way, way past that.
Normal children don't
walk around pretending
to be a dog nearly as much
as you do, for example.
You're 10.
It makes people wonder about
your developmental progress
when you growl and bark at them.
An even more concerning
issue is the obstacle course.
Fine, you want to train your
dog to run through an obstacle
course.
That's pretty normal.
What isn't normal is
making your mother time you
as you crawl through
the course on all fours
over and over again.
You're making mom think
that she did something
wrong to make you this way.
Now that we've gotten
that out of the way,
allow me answer your questions.
Do you still like dogs?
Yes, but not as much as you do.
I've developed a healthy
relationship with dogs.
What is your favorite dog?
I don't know.
This may cause a
surprise to you,
but knowing exactly where
each dog breed ranks
on my list of favorites
isn't the pressing issue
that it used to be.
Do you have a job training dogs?
No.
I can't even train my
own dogs, let alone
the dogs of other people.
Is Murphy still alive?
Of course not.
I don't know
whether you're being
optimistic are you
actually don't understand
that dogs won't live to be 25.
But you really set yourself
up for a lot of disappointment
there.
What is your favorite food?
Nachos.
Which is fortunate,
because in the future,
you're dysfunctional and you
don't take care of yourself.
So you end up eating
a whole lot of nachos.
Are mom and dad still alive?
Actually, you turn
out to be Batman,
so we had to have them put
down for storyline purposes.
Dear 13-year-old.
I think everyone was relieved
when you started to grow out
of your unhealthy
obsession with dogs.
Unfortunately, now you
think you're a wizard.
I know this because I found
your collection of spells.
Tell me, how does mixing
dijon mustard with sand,
and then eating it,
makes someone love you?
[LAUGHTER]
First of all, I thought
that your extensive early
experiences with ingesting
nonfood substances
would put you off of
attempting something like this.
Secondly, no one is
going to love you
until you stop doing things like
trying to make them love you
by eating mustard sand.
Dear other iterations
of my past self.
Thank you for not
being so goddamn
weird that I felt I had
to address you personally
in a letter from the future.
I commend you.
The end.
[APPLAUSE]
So, questions I guess, now?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
ALLIE BROSH: Hi.
AUDIENCE: What's your
writing process like?
ALLIE BROSH: Oh boy.
OK.
So I start out with a really
specific but vague sense
of what I want the
post to feel like
and what I want it to read like.
The problem with
that is that it's
sort of like
looking at something
out of your peripheral vision.
You can't really focus on it.
And so you have to just
steer closer to it.
And you know when
it's really wrong.
You don't know when it's right.
So most of the
writing a post process
is just steering
it closer to what
this arbitrary, weird mental
image I have in my head is.
I also have a folder
system on my desktop.
I have the idea farm.
And that's where there's just
like one-word, random ideas.
Sometimes I don't
even remember what
I was thinking
when I wrote them.
But I revisit that
folder periodically
and try to see if there's
any new perspective that I
have on one of those things.
And if there is a
new perspective--
like maybe a new angle,
something that can actually
steer it toward being an
actual story with structure--
I move it to another
folder, which
is-- what's that one called.
I think it's post-holding area.
And that's where I start
actually working on it
legitimately.
And then once it
starts taking shape,
to the point where I
feel like I can maybe
start adding drawings,
I move it to the folder
called "Look at
this, motherfucker."
And that's to get
me to look at it.
Because I won't otherwise.
And then once it's
in that folder,
I know that it's serious and I
need to take it very seriously
and start drawing pictures.
Does that answer your question?
All right.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
As someone who has
had dead fish before,
I can say that I
really appreciated
that particular comic.
And I think it was
widely recognized
as something that was very human
and an interesting, different
perspective on
the subject than I
think many other people
had ever seen before.
And I think that was really
courageous and great.
ALLIE BROSH: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
for writing that.
And as a follow up question,
what's your favorite dog?
[LAUGHTER]
ALLIE BROSH: My favorite dog?
Oh boy.
A wolf.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Is there a technical
term for the hair piece
that your character wears?
Is it a ponytail?
ALLIE BROSH: OK.
That's-- I sort of have come
to think of it as a shark fin
a little bit.
It did start out as hair.
And then I got sort of annoyed
drawing hair for myself,
and so I just did this
little triangle thing.
And now it's a shark fin.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I just wanted to
say, first of all,
that I don't know if it's the
same post that guy was talking
about, but I really,
really loved the post
about Allie trying to kill the
fish, then she would spare it.
Yeah, that was my favorite.
I was cracking up for ages.
But anyways, I wanted
to ask, you always
seem to have this wealth of
ideas that you write about.
And I was wondering how
you prevent yourself
from hitting blogger's block?
ALLIE BROSH: Well, I feel like I
thought that I was out of ideas
pretty much like three weeks
after I started my blog.
And I don't know.
I just keep going back
to it and keep trying.
Like I said, I write down
in may ideas farm thing,
I just will write down.
Even if I think something's
a horrible idea,
I'll write it down
anyway if it's
a word that maybe is intriguing.
And I've had stuff where I come
back to it three years later.
And it's like, finally.
OK, now I can do
something with this.
Whereas before, I maybe
hadn't had the experience yet
that would allow me to turn
that actually into a story.
There are some stories that
are you had to be there
stories, until I figure out
what the little ironies are,
what the little inconsistencies
are in the story
to draw out to make
it actually funny
and read like there's
a structure to it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ALLIE BROSH: You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
ALLIE BROSH: Oh, hi.
I like your cone.
That's good.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: So your drawings have
this amazing like-- they're
deformed in these weird
ways that are also,
they seem to get across
the emotion more than
if it was just like a
normal looking person.
I'm wondering, do
you know beforehand
how you're going to deform
a face that it looks
so proud and so twisted, or do
you try like a million times?
ALLIE BROSH: I do have
to try a million times.
Like what I was
saying before, where
I have this really vague
but very specific thing.
If that makes sense.
It's a specific sense.
But the image in
my head is vague.
And I have to do quite a
few drafts of my drawings
to get it to look somewhat
close to what I'm imagining.
And so sometimes,
it's actually good
that I don't know what
I'm doing, because I'll
draw something and
I'll be like, oh hey,
I wouldn't have
thought of drawing
that face if I didn't
just take a stab at it.
But yeah, it definitely
takes a really long time
to get the face just right.
Sometimes the people,
the eye, if you
move it even like
half a millimeter,
it makes a huge difference
in the facial expression.
And you wouldn't
think that something
like that would make
such a big difference.
But I guess maybe
just to me it does.
AUDIENCE: Well, they're awesome.
Thank you.
ALLIE BROSH: You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: Did you intentionally
hit on the artistic style
and keep it consistent
intentionally,
or is this just the
thing that came out?
ALLIE BROSH: This is
the thing that came out.
It's been an evolution.
When I first started
drawing my character,
it was just like a circle head
with a triangle body thing.
And since then, there
are things like edits
I've made to it that have slowly
made it what it is today, which
is sort of like this
fish-tadpole-bird thing,
I don't know what.
All the shapes that I
find funny, I guess.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I think your work is really
relatable to a ton of people,
because of how genuine it feels.
You're part of a generation
of authors like Jenny Lawson
and Matt [? Eiman ?] that
you just read their stuff
and you feel so much
like this is something
that could have happened to me.
Or I remember something
that happened me now
that exactly is like that.
I wonder though,
since you're also
a great comedian,
how much of what
you write over the last
four or five years,
do you feel detached from it?
Or do you truly feel
like you're doing
something autobiographical?
Like, do look back
at things you wrote
and you're like, no, that's
exactly how I feel now.
Or do you feel like you
iterate over, again and again,
to make it more of
a polished product?
ALLIE BROSH: I definitely
spend a lot of time polishing.
I think that my job as
a writer or a comedian
is to take whatever
thing is in my head
and figure out how
to translate it most
faithfully into
other people's hands.
And so, that involves a lot
of very specific word choices.
So most of the editing process
is just getting the word
choices down exactly
right to-- it
can be the subtleties and shades
that I'm trying to get across.
As far as how I feel
looking back on stories,
I think I do put myself
in my head-- like,
say when I'm a kid-- I write
from my perspective as a kid.
So my mom is very much the
villain from my perspective.
Clearly, from the
reader's perspective,
she's just being a good mom
and doing what she needs to do.
But yeah, so from my
perspective as a kid,
she was being mean
and evil, and I
think that answers the question.
I feel like I'm rambling.
AUDIENCE: No, that's great.
Thanks
ALLIE BROSH: Hi.
AUDIENCE: So I
imagine these days,
with the book coming out and all
that, you're on the road a lot
and a lot of changes.
How are simple dog and helper
dog dealing with your absence?
ALLIE BROSH: They're good.
We have them staying
with a vet tech
at our veterinary
hospital, and she's great.
She's been sending us pictures
of them just to say, hey,
they're doing good.
But yeah, they're
doing very well.
They've adjusted
to life in bend.
The simple dog knows how to
go up and down the stairs now.
She still sort of
sidewinds though.
Like when she's
going down, she'll
do like this weird thing.
But yeah, they're
doing very well.
AUDIENCE: So I think a lot of
people related to your comic
about the Alot.
ALLIE BROSH: A lot of people.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I was
wondering if-- I find
that I have certain
typographical mistakes that I
make, especially when I'm
typing quickly, that bother me.
And I was wondering
whether a lot was a thing
that you use to help
correct yourself,
or whether there are other
mistakes like that you're
trying to fight?
ALLIE BROSH: So a lot was
never really a problem for me.
The thing that I have problems
with are double letters.
When spelling a word,
I'm great at spelling,
except for if there's a
double letter in there.
If there's two L's or
two T's, I'm fucked.
I don't know how
to spell the word.
So I've been trying
to memorize which
ones have the double letters.
AUDIENCE: So, he beat me
to it, but the Alot post
was really amazing.
ALLIE BROSH: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: But I was
wondering if-- I
don't know how to pronounce it--
spaghatta nadle is coming back
at all?
ALLIE BROSH: People really
like that goddamn noodle.
[LAUGHTER]
I think, eventually, he
will have to come back.
Enough people really like him.
And if I get drunk
or really tired,
sometimes I'm just really in
the mood for spaghatta nadle.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So what made
you start drawing this?
Did it start with the blog?
Did you just draw
things like this
and tell stories about
yourself in the past?
ALLIE BROSH: Yeah.
I mean, I've always
written stories just
as a means to entertain myself.
I used to try to write
books when I was a kid.
They were mostly about guys
fighting things and just going
on adventures where
they fight more things.
So yeah, I guess I was
procrastinating when I actually
started my blog.
I was supposed to be
studying for a physics final
for college.
And I eventually
did study for it,
but at this particular
point, I didn't want to.
And I started to
write stuff online.
And I think the
my style evolved--
I've been thinking a
lot about this lately,
actually-- it's probably
a result, sorry.
I got like 45 minutes
of sleep last night,
so I'm a little
scrambled in the brain.
It's a result of
me subconsciously
trying to reproduce the feel
of stand up comedy on the page.
I watch a lot of
stand up comedy.
And when I first
started just trying
to write without the
pictures, I was sort of
bothered by the fact that there
weren't facial expressions,
or weren't any of
those non-verbal cues
that you can get from
watching a stand up comedian.
And so once I started
experimenting with pictures,
it felt really natural
to have this thing
that you can intersperse
with the text
to give maybe like a
word list interaction.
Or you could say
1,000 things at once,
which is really helpful
for comedic timing.
So that's how that happened.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
How do you remember, or
make up, all the details
about when you were a kid?
[LAUGHTER]
ALLIE BROSH: My memory
starts pretty young.
I have all right memories
of most of the early stuff.
So if I write stories of
when I'm like four and five,
the memories are
a little spotty.
I have to talk to
my mom about some
of the more storyline
relevant details, about like,
for example, in the
post about the cake,
meeting the entire cake.
I remember everything
about that,
except for I don't actually
know how I got into the room
with the cake.
I remember eating it.
I remember throwing it
up all over the place.
But I don't remember
how I got in there.
So with stuff like that, where
I really don't remember--
and it's not a major
like, it's something
like I got into the
room with the cake.
So I just need to find a
way to get to that point.
And I figured the most
logical explanation, knowing
my grandparents'
house, was the window.
So there's a little bit of that.
And sometimes I'll trim stuff
down for like streamlining it
for storyline purposes,
so it's not confusing.
Or, say like, oh,
well I was here
with this person, this
person, and this person.
I'll just like, I was here.
But yeah, they're-- you were
asking about my memories.
I'm really sorry, you guys.
I knew I was going to
crash at some point today.
I woke up and I was so
surprised like, oh man, I
don't feel like as bad as
I thought I would feel.
And now, it's all starting
to come back to me.
It's catching up.
So yeah, hang in there with me.
I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
What would you say
distinguishes you
from your character
named Allie, if anything?
ALLIE BROSH: I think that
my character is actually
a more accurate
representation of me,
like how I really, really am.
It's like inside.
Inside that, that's what I am.
I'm this weird, absurd thing.
And yeah, like when
I talk to myself,
the voice inside my head
is very much this thing.
Me, I'm just yeah.
I relate more to the character.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
ALLIE BROSH: I
love your costume.
AUDIENCE: What costume?
ALLIE BROSH: Oh.
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Thank you for coming.
I was hoping you could
talk a little bit about how
early you get feedback on posts,
how polished you like things
to be before you get
it, who you go to.
ALLIE BROSH: I pretty much just
talk to my husband about it.
He's the only one in like
the inner, inner post circle.
Because I start to
doubt myself when
I'm hammering through
stuff that never
sounds funny in
the very beginning.
Because I'm stumbling over
it, and I'm like oh, well,
there's this part.
And it'll be really
funny, you'll see.
Like, once I draw the
picture, once I draw the eyes,
you'll see it'll
be really funny.
But just imagine this.
And you don't get
the whole picture.
So I do just read it to Duncan.
I guess I share with my editor
and my agent sometimes too.
But most of it just
goes on in my own head.
I leave it for a few days if
I'm really stuck, and come back
and read it and think like, hey.
Is this any better
than I thought it was?
Or maybe I missed something?
Maybe I think it's horrible now?
AUDIENCE: Do you ever
talk to your husband
to get ideas to get you unstuck?
ALLIE BROSH: Yeah, yeah.
We'll go on walks, these
like long, nighttime walks,
and just like hammer
out post ideas.
And we'll pick a topic, like
identity, and say like, well.
What's important
for your identity?
And he'll say to me what's
important for his identity,
and then we'll
just talk about it.
And it's good,
because we just have
an interesting conversation,
and maybe an idea
will spring from that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
ALLIE BROSH: You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: We also have
30% of our offices
on a Hangout view this.
And so if anyone on the Hangout
wants to ask a question,
just unmute in between
questions, and ask away.
And I think we have time
for five more minutes.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'd like to ask a question.
ALLIE BROSH: Where is it?
AUDIENCE: I'm the
disembodied voice.
ALLIE BROSH: I can see me.
I can't see anybody--
AUDIENCE: I, really, really,
really love your blog.
And thank God you're
writing it to me.
I used to have to pet rats.
And I adored them.
And I want to have
them again soon.
But I'd like to know a bit
more about your pet rats.
ALLIE BROSH: They're wonderful.
I rescue them, actually.
We adopt them
from-- so, you guys
have maybe seen the "Hoarders"
episode with the rats.
We adopted some
from that situation.
They took them out
of the house and were
trying to get them homes.
So we have, I think, seven now.
And our oldest two rats are
just the sweetest two rats
in the world.
There's Pizzo, who
is my favorite thing
in the entire universe.
She's roughly potato-shaped
and very soft.
And she's very affectionate.
And then there's Charlie,
who-- Charlie's very special.
She never really settled down.
She's sort of twitchy and
weird about everything.
But I love her to death.
And I could go
through all of them,
but I think that wouldn't
leave very much time
for other questions.
AUDIENCE: But how do they
get along with helper dog?
ALLIE BROSH: The dogs
leave them alone.
They know that the
rat cage is special,
and they shouldn't go
over there and bug them.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ALLIE BROSH: You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: I was going to
ask if you've ever done
or wanted to do any
spoken forms of comedy,
like improv, stand
up, et cetera?
ALLIE BROSH: I actually
would love to do stand up.
I don't know if I have
the stage presence for it.
It terrifies me.
But I love stand up comedy.
And maybe one of these days
I'll take a crack at it.
AUDIENCE: You should.
All kinds of people with
terrible stage presence do it.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: So when
did you first realize
that some of your characters
and their expressions
left your blog and
were used for memes
and other forms of
entertainment on the internet?
And did that change
your writing at all?
ALLIE BROSH: It didn't
change my writing.
I noticed it when people
like my Facebook friends
would post it on my wall, and
be like, did you see this?
No, I did not.
I think one of the
first ones I saw
was somebody using it
on a coffee shop sign,
with the chalk drawings.
And that was pretty cool.
And I see people
will make their own,
and post Alot memes to my wall.
Hey, I see it all the time.
I'm always getting emails
from people being like,
did you see this
one and this one?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: As an artist
and a copyright holder,
how do you feel about that?
[LAUGHTER]
ALLIE BROSH: I like that the
internet is having fun with it.
It's fine when people are
just using it as a meme.
Having fun with it, trying to
be funny, that's totally fine.
It's less fine when they are
using it to sell something
or to like support a really
shitty point of view.
I don't know.
So those times really bother me.
But the other times, I'm
totally fine with it,
when people are just having
fun and trying to be funny.
PRESENTER: I think that's
all we have time for.
Thank you so much.
Allie is going to be
signing books at the back.
So if you want your book signed,
please make an orderly line
towards the back of the room.
Thank you so much for coming.
[APPLAUSE]